so the word fat is a word describes a physical state of being
it's not a feeling
and maybe unpack why
if you were feeling bad about yourself
your first word to describe that is feeling fat
you can feel bloated
you can feel ugly
you can feel uncomfortable
your feelings about yourself
do not change the way that your physical body exists
if I feel thin doesn't you have become Mariah Carey skinny
my feelings don't change the way that my physical body look
I understand having negative feelings about your body
I think it's important to find language
that actually explains what you're feeling
instead of relying on words like fat to describe something that is inaccurate
because again
fat is not a feeling
it's literally just a descriptor of size that's it